c'était Frédéric pedrazak je salue qui
est le patron de TF1 prod qui m'appelle
et qui me dit TF1 aimerait te voir
attention TF1 arrête de voir moi je fais
TPMP ici c'était la première année on
parlait pas mal de moi ça cartonnaise
TF1 je débarque je passe la sécu et le
mec media quitté bébé
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu sens que ça arrive tu sais pourquoi
je vais venir tu veux non mais bon
j'imagine
Danse avec les stars je suis bon très
bien je suis un petit peu vexé de me
dire qu'ils ont enlevé ses routines mais
c'est très bien il me dit voilà donc tu
sais comment c'est quand même c'est une
belle émission c'est très prime
j'en parle à Cyril mais oui très près
oui ça me paraît bien et donc voilà tu
danseras avec G7 d'ailleurs et en plus
tu es un peu gaulé torse nu [ __ ] on se
parlerait de ta maman il y aura un truc
un peu tout le temps et tout mais si je
comprends ce que tu me dis là c'est pour
être danseur c'est pour ça
c'est pas pour l'animé pas du tout c'est
pas du tout